[Music]
[Music]
i am going to be live coding today for
the book map for programmers with
manning publication the idea behind this
book is that a lot of programmers out
there are interested in things like
graphics and machine learning or
simulations or you know cryptography
or
data science and all these things take a
lot of math to make them work i had the
idea to kind of put a lot of different
stuff uh you know
related to math and also related to
these domains in computer programming uh
in one book so that anyone who is
interested kind of getting into the more
mathematical domains in computer
programming could kind of have an
approachable place to start you can
access the source code
directly from the book website on
manning and basically you get a zip and
there's one folder per chapter if you
want to start playing with the source
code for this session i decided not to
do anything directly out of the book
instead i wanted to kind of show
something that was using some of the
concepts from the book but doing a kind
of new application that that isn't
directly covered in the book so what i'm
going to be covering is a mathematical
concept called fractals
and fractals if you just search for
fractal
um
you can find a bunch of cool pictures of
what a fractal is fractals are these
kind of weird complex geometric things
so if you there's some that are
recognizable this is the
mandelbrot set this is a special fractal
this is the sir pinsky triangle if i'm
not mistaken
so you can find a bunch of these online
if you search and they're all
they're all cool to look at there's a
lot of math that underlies these these
fractal um graphics and
it's actually despite how complicated
these look
uh relative to some of the geometric
things you may have seen in in the math
class they're actually pretty simple to
define
so i guess probably the simplest thing
to do
is to show you guys on wikipedia
i'm sure they have a list of fractals
here
um let's see i think there's a good one
here here's one that's called the
sierpinski carpet this is a good example
of a fractal because it shows you that
one of the key properties of a fractal
is that it's self-similar so in the
middle here of the fractal you have
um this black square
and then basically what the fractal is
defined at is this black square in the
middle and then
uh there are eight copies of the fractal
around the outside so
um
each if you look at any of these eight
kind of um
boxes around the edge you'll see that
each of them has a black square in the
middle and then there are eight more
copies
around the edge
uh that look like the whole like the
whole figure so if you zoom in
uh you continue to see no matter how far
you zoom you'll just see more and more
shapes that are
um kind of like identical to the uh
appearance of the whole thing what we'll
do today in the next hour or so is i'll
use some of the concepts from the book
math for programmers and we'll generate
some cool kind of self-similar shapes
like this
um and then talk a little bit more about
the uh you know the concept of fractals
and what they are if you've got the
source code downloaded from after
programmers and we won't use it directly
but i just wanted to show you guys
where it is for for context like i said
it's organized by chapter um most of the
chapters have a
jupiter notebook
which is i i should i should say
first of all all of the code for math
for programmers is done in python and
python is one of the best languages to
use if you're learning math and
especially if you're if you're doing
math in code
there are a couple reasons for that
first of all python is
a very it's a simple language um
and it's um
widely used uh second of all it's got a
lot of good libraries for
uh numerical and mathematical
computations so
um it's kind of the de facto standard
for data science and uh and for machine
learning
so um further within python there's this
this tool called um jupiter which is a
way of kind of having a more visual
version of a interactive session like
you know you can obviously type python
commands into a interactive session like
many scripting languages but you can
also can show you an example here in the
source code you can also put together a
notebook and what a jupyter notebook
looks like is the following so it's kind
of like you type code into a box
and then
when you execute it you could get output
that's either text like would come out
in your command line or you can get
a picture like this this is the graphic
generator by this code so jupyter is
such a common technology
and a way for organizing code that
actually when you put a jupiter notebook
on github you can see
um
the whole kind of session
drawn out here i really like this for
the for the book math for programmers
because it gives you a kind of
reproducible way to go through all of
the code from the chapter otherwise it's
kind of hard because you you know you
see a line of code in the book but then
how do you kind of put it together into
a working example so i hope that if you
guys download this and you have all the
prerequisites set up
which are detailed in the appendix for
math for programmers that you can kind
of just run this end to end and work
through all of the examples
um and i hope that that make this makes
this book approachable so in some
chapters that's not the case and there's
some things that you can't do
in a jupiter session like if you want to
have something that's that's interactive
or real time
is not convenient it may be possible but
it's not convenient to have it in the
jupyter notebook
i can show you an example of that
and i think it's chapter
old folder
okay let's try um
chapter uh nine
um so in chapter nine we use um
an algorithm to
do simulation based on physics equations
called euler's method
and
if you do chapter 9 then you will end up
building
a little video game
because i have to go to that folder
first
uh and you guys have probably seen this
type of video game before it's pretty
famous so this is like a an asteroid
game where you have a little
spaceship and then there's some
asteroids and then you can shoot them
um and you try and avoid them so this
this takes you know takes the math of
deciding where in this kind of grid
you're going to draw each of these
polygons and how you're going to make
them move and how you're going to make
them rotate so that's covered in the
book
um but i'll use this as the starting
point for
uh
for what we're doing today with fractals
so if you want to if you want to kind of
review the math to get ready for this
coding session you can look at chapter
nine and that'll show you how to kind of
make the animations that we'll do and
handle the key presses you guys can't
see it right now but i'm i'm pressing on
my keyboard to kind of steer the ship
and actually chapter seven chapter nine
will show you how to make the asteroids
game
and then chapter two will kind of fill
in some of the more basic concepts of
how do you represent polygons and how do
you uh you know what how do you use the
points on the coordinate plane i'll kind
of go over that as we go today but um
that's that's kind of to catch you up on
where we're going to start
let's see
so the example that i put together for
today is uh we'll make something that
looks like this
so this basically you can see it's kind
of the same coordinate grid here as from
the first example but i put together a
fractal here so it's a this is a
self-similar geometric object you can
see that it's kind of like
the square the big square
and then
next to it there are two little squares
and basically this pattern is repeated
everywhere you see an edge now so
uh here's an edge
of the original fractal and you see a
big square and two little squares next
to it and then on top of this little
square there's big square and two little
squares next to it this is just one
example we can maybe do a couple
different examples but the other thing
that i wired up here is i just like the
asteroid game i wired up so if you press
different keys you can zoom in
and see the fractal closer up so you can
actually see a little bit more detail
as you zoom in here
yeah so that's the basic idea i guess
we'll get started now and i'll kind of
just talk through for the exam this
example i'll talk through how to write
some of the code to make this work and
then also some of the mathematical ideas
that are that are behind the fractal or
you know this fractal in particular and
then fractals in general so to start
basically i put together this fresh
version and let me make sure it's called
fractals start
and let's see it doesn't have much so i
wanted to make sure before we before i
got started that i had something
um i had something going here so here's
a
just a single polygon this is a triangle
uh obviously and i i wanted to make sure
that i could draw this using the python
code
and so basically we'll do everything
else to get to a fractal starting from
this single polygon so i'm not going to
explain all of the code here i'll i'll
give you a sense of the big things that
are going on
and like i said if you want to
understand the code at a deeper level a
lot of this came from chapter
uh what i say chapter
9 of the book math for programmers so
you can find it online there are a
couple of libraries python libraries
that are imported here
there are a couple of
colors and settings so i set the width
and the height of the game screen i set
the width and the height of the game
screen to 800 pixels each to kind of
make it big
and then
uh the next thing you that are you know
at least in this code file i think it's
also in the code for chapter nine is
there's a couple of helper functions so
when we're working with this
all of our
all of our
computations will be done in this
coordinate system where this is like
0 0 and this is you know one unit and
this is the x-axis and this is the
y-axis
so you all have one unit in the x
direction two units in the x direction
etcetera um so basically your
coordinates for a point are
you know however many in the x direction
so maybe one two three four five and
then
and then however many y direction one
two three so this is the point five
comma three um and you know if you
haven't
maybe you you probably remember this
from a high school math class or
something how to find points in the
coordinate plane but if you don't um
this is all covered in in chapter two of
math for programs what i want to do is i
want to think about geometry in this
coordinate plane
and then have it automatically convert
everything to pixels for me so
um that's that's what this helper
function does if i have an x and a y
coordinate uh in this coordinate plane
then it basically does the math
automatically in terms of the height and
width to find the pixel values and to
render the appropriate number of pixels
so if you can draw a point with
at a certain pixel location
you can automate the process of drawing
a polygon or drawing a line segment or
drawing this actually this grid itself
is a
kind of putting a helper function where
it draws all of these vertical and
horizontal
um
lines to show me the coordinate axes
um
and i think that's that's all you really
need to see for the helper functions for
now
so
um then we get to the main function so
this this is the function that'll be
called when you actually start this
python script
and this is mostly using a python
library called pygame pygame is a
framework designed to help you create a
interactive game uh simply in the python
programming language
so it basically gives me tools to
create that screen you saw make it
interactive
have it refresh on a recurring basis so
we can animate it
and
a lot of that is explained in the
appendices of math for programmers
because we use pi game in a couple of
chapters
so the main part of the pi game program
is this thing called a
game loop so it's while
um well not done well basically what we
haven't said to shut down the
screen
it's going to do a bunch of things over
and over again
and the first one is it updates the
clock so there's a clock in the
background and then
while let's see
i guess if you press the x button on
that screen
um
if you press this x button it exits and
it breaks this while loop um but
otherwise it doesn't set this done to
true and it keeps looping through this
so
it knows the number of milliseconds that
have elapsed since the last frame
um
and then it basically does some drawing
in every frame kind of like you can
think of frames of the movie
and every
uh every time it it sort of goes through
this while loop it'll draw a new frame
and that's how you saw
um in the first fractal i showed you
let's see
and the first fractal i showed you that
actually animates so this is every time
i hold down a key on my keyboard uh
it's animating it's drawing a new
version of the fractal and um in every
frame and that's why you see it getting
bigger so just drawing it over and over
again
um okay so now i'm back in this i'm back
in this fractal start file where i've
only got one polygon
and what we'll do is we will draw a
similar uh kind of
fractal this like self-similar complex
geometric pattern um starting from here
and
you can see there's there's a couple of
lines that are drawn every frame of this
animation there's not you don't see it
moving but it is an animation this is
being redrawn
some number of times every second to get
this triangle showing up
the first thing that happens in in every
loop and in every frame
is that the screen is filled with white
so we basically blank out everything
that's on the screen
and then um
this grid is drawn so you see the
horizontal and vertical grid lines
that's what draw grid does
and then you get draw drop poly draws a
polygon and it there's this screen
variable that represents that window
so draw polygon is this wrapper that
takes on the screen and then it takes in
a list of coordinates which are the
vertices of the polygon what you've got
here are one one and that is let's see
one one will be one in the x direction
one the y direction so that's this
vertex
and then you've got negative one one
um
and that is let's see
negative one one will be this vertex and
then the last one will be negative 1
negative 1
which is this guy here negative 1 in the
x direction and then negative 1 in the y
direction so those three together give
us our triangle and this draw poly
function kind of knows how to fill that
in so i guess as a first
example maybe i'll try i'll try making
this a little bit bigger
we've got a lot of screen space
to work with
so if you change all of the
um if you change all of the numbers and
make them bigger then everything will
get bigger by the
corresponding factor let's take a look
and see what this does you have to
restart the python script
uh and you can see the triangle route
papers now it's like 3 3
negative 3 three and negative three
negative three
um okay so that's that's a good start
maybe we can actually i didn't plan on
doing this we can try doing a triangle
based fractal in this um in this demo
and see where that gets us instead of
the other example that i showed you
which was based on kind of a
self-similar pattern of squares so
first of all let's try we're going to
obviously have to draw a lot of
different triangles if we're going to
make this self-similar pattern
let's just try putting a second triangle
on the screen
and seeing if we can get it to show up
so
i'll put another triangle the same shape
but a different size i'll put it up here
um so maybe i'll put it at
let's see i'll start it at um
what would this be this would be three
six
and i'll have to go to six zero six
and then
zero three so it'll be this triangle
here so when i say three six
zero six
and
zero
three
okay so yeah this is um this is now a
second triangle that i've drawn here and
you know you can see that i had to just
kind of measure out where i was gonna
put the uh
i was gonna put the each of the vertices
and then i listed them and then i passed
them to draw poly
you